hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar high throughput genotoxicity
assays for DNA damage and mode of action
analyses i am michelle ashton of
Labatt's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Milton E biotech to learn more
about our sponsor please visit
www.sap.com/learnbi
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in to be asked a
question box and click send our speakers
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers free continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speakers dr.
Jeffrey DeMuth the director of clinical
studies at light Ron laboratories in ma
Chester New York and dr. Jakob once the
product manager of flow cytometry
instruments at Milton E biotech for a
complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tabs at the
top of your screen
Jeffrey and Jacob will now begin their
presentations
I welcome everybody to today's webinar
about high-throughput genotyping essays
for DNA damage and mode of action
analysis
we will discuss how you can modernize
your genotoxicity testing and in which
point you can improve your test
performance in the most beneficial way
I'm dr. yaker bonza product manager at
Milton Ivy Tech and I'm very proud to
have dr. Jeffrey Bemis speaking here
today he's the director of the clinical
studies at litem laboratories in
Rochester in the state of New York
thank you Jeff for sharing some of your
expert knowledge on genotoxicity testing
with us today
dr. Bemis we will discuss simple and
efficient essays for the DNA damage and
multiple endpoint studies and how
high-throughput solutions improve your
genotoxicity testing setups in before I
will shortly introduce in the use of
flow cytometry in Geno toxicology and
how our instruments reagents and
software solutions will benefit your
setup
with this set I will hand over to the
interesting part of dr. Bemis
reduction and refinement these are the
well-known three hours of the concept
first described by Rosalind Burge 1959
in their book the principles of human
experimental techniques
roundabouts 60 years later this concept
are now the basis of many national and
international laws
which regulates the proper use of in
vivo experiments and laboratory animals
even if we are still far from completely
replacing necessary in vivo experiments
the Junge path could show that use of
appropriate flow cytometry
based in vivo assays is often capable of
reducing animal experiments not only
this but rather more they are also
economically beneficial in terms of time
expenses and convenience especially
compared to extensive microscopic based
analysis
to get a little bit more into detail
we'll have a look at the very very own
regulatory background of chemical
testing
the requirements differ depending on the
region as well at the type of chemical
under regulation
for example in the EU for cosmetics and
vivo experiments are prohibited but
instead different in vitro tests are
required
chemicals biocides veterinary drugs or
plant protection products the regulatory
requirements for c to cover multiple
endpoints by in vitro testing especially
in case of bio sites and industrial
chemicals a clearly negative results of
this test impede further in vivo testing
the regulation for pharmaceuticals as
well for C's in vitro testing in
combination with in vivo testing
in the most of these cases the choice of
the right in vitro testing is crucial
several oacd approved flow satchel
metric based tests can simplify workflow
and make the difference
current analyzers bring the best
qualification for high-throughput
genotyping GSA's
for reliable and automated data
acquisition the max quant analyzer
tennis your trusted partner with it's up
to 8 colors and the ability of our
express mode pack packages this very
small size analyzer is more than capable
of standardized and toxicological essays
the Crypt violet blue and red laser are
spatially separated and built the center
of a very robust optical system
from startup to shutdown
then the maximun another 10 brings
abroad offer of automated applications
such as hands-free calibration sample
labeling and compensation also very
powerful is the volumetric account which
does not require any beats
this is more makes the max content
analyser a very reliable and simple
partner
another key piece for your successful
essays are the right reagents in the
past years the subject raced that one
main reason for the issue was
reproducing reproducibility and data
acquisition is based on inconsistent
antibodies in 2018 it was discussed that
even antibodies derived from hybridoma
are more frequently equipped with
additional functional variable regions
to dispose this problem we developed our
own riaf energy recombinant antibodies
this antibodies are defined on the
genetic sequence which also ensures lots
of odd consistency the antigen binding
regions are specified and validated for
slow flow cytometry and further we use a
universal igg1 isotope backbone to
simplify X your experiment
additionally the F theory region is
mutated to eliminate the background
noise of the FC receptor this makes our
Rio finiti recommend antibody reliable
and consistent choice
another unimportant area in which you
really can improve your analytic
workflow is software applications I
would like to show you two beneficial
applications which will simplify your in
vitro analysis with high reproducibility
run our Express mode to ensure automated
and standardized data acquisition we
developed an algorithm which is
optimized to get your panel and dust the
analysis fully automated Express modes
are sustainable even within high sample
to sample variation
they will simplify your flow cytometry
essays via predefined experiments data
acquisition and analytic settings in a
standardized way the algorithm is
developed and trained with a huge amount
of data and adjust the gating for each
single data file individually this
ensures read reproducible results in
this we can say that standardized
algorithm based data analysis can reduce
human error creates reproducible results
provides standardized analysis based on
mathematics and simplifies your SOP
based processes
everybody knows that if you measure the
same experiment with two different
devices even if they are from the same
type you will get different results
maybe you also already tried to manual
normalize the differences in the
photomultiplier voltages and now the
struggle in this therefore the second
application our smart games
automatically calculates an intrinsic
normalization and sets the gain for each
device to 400
this ensures the exact same instrument
setting from instrument to instrument
and therefore an equivalent performance
this smart games like a lighthouse
consistently guides your instruments to
reproducible and reliable data from test
tests independent of the user on all
instruments and all over the world
standardization and robustness are the
key points of our portfolio consisting
of optimized reagents instruments and
software applications which reach from
research use only till the regulated
environment I hope you could find
beneficial solution also for you area if
you are interested or you have questions
please don't hold back and ask me after
we listen to dr. Bemis or you could
write me an email to J AKO b b @ ms lee
biotech de or you take a look at our
website and anthony biotech calm now I
know we are all waiting for I will hand
over to dr. Jeffery Bemis who will
further discuss the high-throughput
applications on genetics testing
especially is an expert in DNA damage
testing and multiplex genotoxicity
screaming again very well welcome Jeff
and thank you very much for having you
here
thanks Yakko I appreciate that
introduction and I also want to thank
the audience for joining in with us
today so I'm going to start right out in
our discussion of high-throughput
genotyping a sage with a quick little
introduction about light Ron just to
give you a perspective from where we're
coming from
we've been in the genetic toxicology
business for over 40 years and primarily
focusing on the development of new and
novel approaches not only for
preclinical product safety testing which
is where the bulk of our work is done
but in addition we do some clinical
research applications of these same
endpoints as well
all of our assays are basically centered
around flow cytometry and that is going
to be the theme of today's talk high
throughput instruments combined with
high information content assays so the
octave has given us a nice introduction
to the instruments and I'm going to
focus for the rest of this presentation
more on the assay side the reason that
we're doing this is we believe these
higher information content assays can
improve compound screening have a nice
complement to those regulatory required
assays that Jakob was describing earlier
they can expand the range of information
that you can get from the assays that
you have to do and then ultimately again
as Jakob was describing they do address
multiple aspects of 3hours initiatives
so before we get too far into the essays
I want to define a few different terms
that you'll be hearing me use throughout
this presentation just so that we're all
on the same page they might not be terms
that you're familiar with if you're not
a genetic toxicologist so I'm going to
start out with a couple of these
definitions the first is a class again
this is a classification of a type of
Geno toxic compound that results in DNA
double strand breaks and you can see a
picture of nucleus over there that has
been experiencing exposure to a class
gin in this case a classic exposure of
ionizing radiation this is very well
known for causing the DNA double strand
breaks a very cytotoxic lesion that were
definitely need to be interested in if
we're looking at genotoxicity so class
agen is one type or a mode of action of
genotoxicity
the next one that I'm going to be
talking about is antigens these are
durations in the segregation or the way
that the cells handle chromosomes
primarily through division when they're
lining up at the mitotic plate as you
can see here in this picture we've got a
nice division of chromosomes that are
moving to either poles of the daughter
cells and that's the way it's supposed
to be all of these chromosomes are
supposed to segregate equally if you
have alterations in that if you had
disruptions in the segregation male
segregation of those chromosomes you can
end up with an eg city which is
obviously a significant toxic effect
going on in the cells you can also get
polyploidy which is sort of an outcome
where you have too many chromosomes in
one and not enough chromosomes into
another I'll show you some examples of
that later on so we've got these two
different classes of class tagine or
excuse me of geno toxic agents class
surgeons and antigens and finally the
other category that we kind of lump
everything else into would be non Geno
toxicants now many of these may be just
as cytotoxic as those classes genes or
antigens but they do that through other
mechanisms and in fact they may
ultimately damage DNA but they're
primarily doing it through secondary
pathways some examples of that would be
apoptosis or damage to lysosomes etc but
it's not a direct type of DNA damage
such as we would see with other classes
or antigens I'm going to go over a
couple of the current and vitro
approaches this kind of looks back at
the slide that jakob showed a little bit
earlier and talking about the different
batteries for regulatory genotoxicity
testing these are some of the specific
tests that make up those batteries and
in effect i'm talking specifically about
the in vitro approaches here so we're
looking in this case at the ames
bacterial mutation assay some of you may
be familiar with this as a classic assay
that gets used all the time and is still
a requirement for submission of
compounds for regulatory approval the
comet assay is another well-known assay
that is again looking at DNA strand
breaks similar to what we were talking
about before that would be caused by
classy genes there are a couple of other
ones that do get used every once in a
while that's the chromosomal aberration
assay which is again a chromosome
damaging endpoint there's some other
assays hprt Mouse lymphoma assay these
are a little bit more specialized and
not quite as commonly used as the final
one that I'm going to be talking about
which is the in vitro mark a nuclei
- si and again this is our indicator of
chromosome damage that we're looking at
and I'm going to spend a significant
portion of the rest of the talk to
addressing this with our in-vitro
micronucleus si called in vitro micro
flow so we're looking at micronucleus
assessment in cell lines and this is the
assay that we have devised at light Ron
laboratories the weight of this system
works is we're using tk6 human
lymphoblastoid cells primarily and we've
exposed them to our test article the
compound that we want to find out
whether it's genotoxic or not so within
that mix of cells we have some healthy
cells we have some my canoe plated cells
if there was AG no toxic insult that
they experienced we have some necrotic
cells and in some cases we may have some
a pop tonic cell so we have this whole
mix of cells after we've done our
exposure and then we start processing
them the first step is exposure to a
nucleic acid ia this is site tox screen
in this case there excuse me this is
Ophidian mono a site that we use here
and what we're doing here is it's a red
dye I'm using that as the indicator on
the right hand side of this picture and
you're seeing that it is getting in and
binding to the DNA of cells would
compromise membranes so those that are
in the product those are a pop tonic
those that have experienced a
significant amount of damage not
necessarily directly associated with
genotoxicity but this allows us to first
pass identify those cells that are dead
or dying then the next dye that we use
is site ox green in this case and we're
adding that at the same time that we're
adding a lysis reagent so we're actually
liberating the nuclei from those cells
and looking at the nuclei the micro
nuclei and any other cell fragments that
are in that cell population this gets
run through the faucet ometer and I'm
going to show you a couple of plots of
that next these aren't all the plots
that we use for defining the different
populations but these are sort of the
two more important ones the one on the
left hand side has that site ox green
nucleic acid dye on the y-axis and on
the bottom the x-axis is that EMA red
dye what we're able to do is
differentiate healthy cells from
unhealthy cells so the population that's
kind of in that lower right casting down
in that region underneath the the
demarcation line there
those are considered dead or dying cells
since they've taken up a TM a die based
on their compromised membranes that
allows us to get an indication of how
much toxicity is happening and actually
gate those cells out and only look at
the healthy nuclei so when we go to this
final plot here where we've kind of
switched around the axes a little bit
I've moved that site tox green dye to
the x-axis in this case and we're
looking at forward scatter or an
indication essentially of size of the
particle on the y-axis that population
that blue population in the upper
right-hand part are the healthy cells so
that's kind of if you're familiar with
flow cytometry it might look a little
bit like a cell cycle where you can see
g1 d2m populations of cells there and
that's the healthy cell population and
then in the lower right hand popular
areas scuse me lower left-hand section
we're looking at the micro nuclei so
those are much smaller and less dense
than the intact nuclei and therefore
they are lower in forward scatter and
lower inside tox green fluorescence that
is where we actually enumerate the
number of micro nuclei that we are
seeing in the cells now it's not the
only thing that we get from this because
flow cytometry is a multi parametric
system we can get multiple types of
different information out of that not
just looking at micro nucleus formation
so in addition to getting those micro
nuclei and nuclei either a little bit
more clearly defined here you can see
them labeled we also get information on
those main nuclei to look at things such
as cell cycle which can be significantly
altered following exposure to a
genotoxic agent I'm showing you an
example of that here where you can see
the gray profile is from a controlled
cell type and then the clearer dark
outlined cell cycle profile is from a
genotoxic agent causing a d2m block so
there's a significant change in the cell
cycle age you can see there it's very
characteristic of a GNote Oxitec spoe
sure we're also adding in a bead so we
have a latex micro particle in there and
a known concentration and this allows us
to look at the ratio between the number
of nuclei and beads in each of the
samples and give you an indication of
cytotoxicity so that when you compare
the nuclei to bead ratio in the control
samples versus the increasing
concentrations of your test article you
can begin to see alterations in
the number of nuclei whereas the beads
stay the same and from that you can
determine the cytotoxicity based on
indices such as relative survival
relative increased cell count which is a
very important part of the guidelines if
you're familiar with the the assessment
of genotoxicity for regulatory studies
you need to have a very good indication
of cytotoxicity because those two things
kind of go in hand Jeannot toxic
compounds are by nature cytotoxic and
therefore you need to control that very
well in order to dial in the assessment
of genotoxicity rather than just looking
at frank cytotoxicity so we get all of
this information and that's a lot for a
single cell but we've increased the
ability and the efficiency of the assay
to give you not only lots of information
about a single well but lots of wells
across a single study and we're using
that and taking advantage of the
different types of analytical platforms
that are out there and processing
platforms and the one I'm going to focus
on today is over on the right hand side
that's at Mill attending Mac's quant 10
system that Jakob was just describing
the automated auto sampler on here that
does robotic sampling of a 96-well plate
is what allows us to do that high
throughput walk away kind of operations
so instead of historically where you
used to have to sit in front of the flow
cytometry and feed sample tubes in for
every individual sample you needed to
run this machine does it for you and
makes walk away operations possible this
then allows you to significantly
increase the types of studies that
you're doing in terms of comprehensive
dose response assessment so in this case
we're looking at probably one of the
most exhaustive executions of our assay
in terms of looking at a single compound
at 22 different concentrations per
experiment we're looking at a very close
dose pacing much finer than half
dilution and based on the diagram that
you're looking at here in the upper
left-hand corner where we have the
highest concentrations going down to the
lower right hand side where you have the
lowest concentrations we're covering
over three orders of magnitude of a
concentration range and we're looking in
quadruplicate at each one of those
experimental conditions so we're getting
a significant amount of information out
of a single study out of a single plate
to give you a very calm
pensive assessment of what is going on
in terms of that test article exposure
what this then allows you to do is get
very fine detail in terms of dose
response modeling and to apply things
such as benchmark dose which if you're
not familiar with it is a type of point
of departure metric that you can use to
look at the potency of different
compounds so what you do is basically
come up with all the different dose
response data for each of your test
articles and then you can rank them
according to the different end points
that you've looked at so in this case
I'm looking on the x-axis at in vitro
marker nucleus frequency and we've got a
benchmark dose looking at a very
specific change in the critical effect
size of the effect or the response of
increasing micronucleus
and on the excuse me on the y axis we're
looking in a comparison against gamma
h2x staining which is our DNA
double-strand rate you would expect both
of these to be fairly consistent with
each other because double strand breaks
lead to micronucleus formation and in
fact we're seeing a very nice
correlation between those two end points
in terms of the most potent compounds
for either one of those endpoints being
localized to the lower left-hand portion
of the of the plot and the least potent
compounds being in the upper right-hand
portion so this is a very nice
confirmation of the micro nucleus
endpoint that we're looking at in terms
of ranking compounds based on their
potency
so in terms of the conclusions for in
vitro mark the nucleus and our micro
flow system we're achieving chromosome
damage assessment in vitro quite readily
by flow cytometry it's important to
exclude the chromatin of those dead and
dying cells because we don't want that
to interfere with our assessment of true
genotoxicity as I showed you before and
we've determined that flow cytometry can
provide more than just those micro
nucleus counts we're getting information
on cytotoxicity based on relative
survival relative increased cell counts
we can look at those cell cycle
perturbations that can be caused by
genotoxic agents we're getting
information on membrane integrity and
finally a little bit of information on
mode of action as well I'm going to go
into that in more detail in the latter
part of this session finally one of the
things I wanted to discuss here really
quickly is we've done a number of
performance assessments it's not just
performance of the assay in light on
laboratory since you guys are coming at
this from potential users what I want to
do relay here is a large multi lab
validation trial that we did with
multiple different pharmaceutical
companies and where you sent them kits
and they assess them across the number
of different test articles that we all
looked at and then we compared our
results and you can see excellent
transferability information on influence
of a pop top the genes as well as
numerous other aspects of executing that
assay across multiple different
laboratories that's in our citation from
Dwight's at all--and 2013 if you're
interested in any of these papers you
should be able to find them quite
readily online otherwise you can request
them from me so now I'm going to move on
to the second part of our session we're
talking about our sort of additional
assay where we're looking at a multiplex
genotoxicity screening in cell line so
it's something that we're kind of
positioning a little bit ahead of
micronucleus testing and this is using
our in vitro multi flow system
the reason that we created this is there
was a bit of a problem with those
traditional in-vitro toxicity in vitro
genotoxicity tests that I've been
describing to date especially when those
manual systems that are out there
there's a significant issue with
throughput and scalability so you really
can't do high numbers of compounds if
you needed to look at large libraries or
do a lot of screening it's difficult to
approach those with those traditional
systems they also do have some issues
with specificity and that there is a an
elevated false positive rate coming from
those particular approaches which
obviously isn't something that you want
to have to deal with if you can come up
with better assays to to replace them
and finally mode of action information
is kind of lacking in some of those
systems in the fact that you can't get
additional information beyond something
is jino toxic or not so our proposed
solution was to identify a number of
different biomarkers that we can use to
discriminate not only genotoxic from non
genotoxic but if it is a genotoxic
compound well is it a class to gene and
antigen or a non genotoxic n' and we
wanted to multiplex those biomarkers
together into a simple ad read type
assay what we devised is our multi flow
system and this is our one step and read
type assay so what you do in the upper
left-hand portion of this diagram is you
have the cells that have been exposed to
your test article you take the portion
of those cells you mix them with our
working reagents coming from our kits
and oh excuse me all at once all of the
outer membranes are liked and stained
simultaneously there are no washing
steps there are no secondary labeling
steps all of this occurs in the same
well once you've mixed the reagents with
the cells and you've got exposure to the
different fluorescent antibodies again
just in the nuclei like we were doing
before we've liked the cells more
isolating our analysis just to the
nuclei of those cells specifically we
are using a nucleic acid stain to look
at just those nuclei and identify them
for further assessment of our flow
centimetric analysis we've included a
antibody against anti h2ax so this is a
DNA double strand break marker as I was
describing before we also have an
antibody in there against phospho
histone h3 which is our marker of
mitotic cells and the finally the one
you may be most familiar with is an
antibody against p53 which is a more
of genotoxic stress specifically in this
case we're kind of looking at a nuclear
translocation mechanism because again
p53 is found in the cytoplasm but since
we voiced the cell and we're only
looking at the nuclei we're essentially
isolating this to all those p53
molecules that have migrated to the
nucleus and therefore that's where we're
looking at our indicator of genotoxic
stress which is similar to our previous
assay we're looking at including a
counting bead in there as well so we can
get indications of cytotoxicity from the
nuclei to bead ratio similar to what we
were doing in our previous essay
during development of this assay we
looked at a training set of compounds
we're looking at over 84 different
compounds that were taken from the exam
list that were well established and
characterized in terms of their
antigenic classes genic or non genotoxic
potential we're doing this again in TK 6
cells treating them in 96-well plates
we're looking at a solvent usually in
DMSO top concentration of 1 milli molar
we're doing up to 20 different closely
spaced concentrations using a square
root 2 dilution scheme in single wells
this time there are concurrent solvent
and positive controls on the plate we do
a 24-hour continuous exposure but we can
actually go in and sample them at
different time points this is since this
is a suspension cell line we're taking
samples at 4 hours and 24 hours across
the 9600 plate across the 20 different
closely spaced concentrations this gives
us an awful lot of information about the
test articles that we're looking at some
of the examples of that information
we're looking at a prototypical classes
in here this is MN ng and on the left
hand side we're looking at our indicator
of DNA double strand breaks that's the
gamma h2ax marker you can see at both 4
and 24 hours we're seeing significant
increases in that indicator of DNA
double strand breaks because this is a
class j'en and in this causing DNA
breakage the next panel over the pH 3
phosphoryl histone h3 is actually
showing a reduction and this is due to a
mitotic block which is characteristic of
cells that are undergoing this clash so
genic type of activity and therefore
this is characteristic of a class Jin to
see reductions in phosphorus tone h3
labeling we see increases at both 4 and
24 hours with p53 our indicator of
genotoxic stress and finally our final
indicator polyploidy we don't see any
change in that particular endpoint
because this is a class digit when we
switch over to an antigen we're seeing a
very different set of responses here so
when the gamma h2x essentially see no
changes throughout either 4 or 24 hours
of exposure but in this case the
phosphoryl histone h3 marker is
significantly elevated both f4 hours and
24 hours over at p53 we see an increase
in 24 hours but we do not see it
we can't increase it for hours with most
antigens so again that's a little bit
different from the class jhin's and then
finally at 24 hours we see a nice
increase a very robust increase in
polyploidy a very well known
characteristic of the antigen exposure
now when you think about all of those
characteristics as I've just been
describing across all of those different
wells across multiple say 96-well plates
that you run in today this really isn't
the most efficient way to look at data
and to start getting information back
out of your test articles and your study
so what we really needed to do was think
about different ways of analyzing the
data and to move from what some people
have called eyeball metrics which we
were just kind of doing on that previous
slide just looking at the data and
switch to something that's more
quantitative objective and a transparent
method for returning information and
making true genotoxicity call so we
explored a number of different data
driven approaches based on that training
set that we ran and ultimately came to
combining of several different machine
learning types of models to give you
that sort of wisdom of the crowd
approach across several different
applications of machine learning and
then to follow that up and to test the
models that we generated we created some
external test sets of new compounds that
I will give you an example of in the
next couple of slides what we're looking
at here before we go too much further I
kind of wanted to give you a little bit
of a concept of machine learning because
I think this term gets tossed around a
lot and people hear about it multiple
different times but some people get kind
of intimidated by this and they just
kind of ignore it and just say oh well
I'll leave that to those computational
science people and they'll just figure
it out for me but it's really a fairly
simple sort of concept when you think of
it just in terms of pattern recognition
so I've put an object up here that I'm
sure we're all very familiar with this
is the stop sign and I'm sure you
recognize it as soon as you saw it come
up on your screen there's a number of
different characteristics or patterns
within this stop sign that we can
extract from that object and we can sort
of look at them in pieces so we've got
the word stop and then we've got the red
color and then we've also got the shape
that sort of octagonal shape those are
all different characteristics or factors
that go into making up that stop sign
and in fact they're all the different
things that our brain essentially puts
together to recognize all those
different patterns and ultimately have
us make some sort of response to that we
see the stop sign we
you're going to stop at that
intersection we can apply this to new
situations because of the different
patterns that we've understood based on
our learning and we can apply that to
new situations and new experiences so in
this case when I put up an unknown slide
that looks very similar to this so we
can see the same color the same shape
but we don't know the word that is there
in this case it's also in the context of
it's at an intersection and perhaps them
in a car I've used my previous learning
my machine learning in this case that my
brain is doing to recognize the
different factors and then make a
prediction as to what I'm supposed to do
here which would be stopped at that
intersection even though I don't speak
the language that is on that sign this
is really what pattern recognition is
about in terms of machine learning and
that's essentially what I'm asking these
different machine learning models to do
with the data that we are obtaining from
our method so we were using three
different models in this case to
specifically go into the details we've
got logistic regression we've got
artificial neural network and then we
have a random forest model we've
combined them all together and we take a
majority vote of the way those call and
we get information back on genotoxicity
assessment now I don't have the time to
go into all the different examples here
I'm just going to show you one specific
example here where we're looking at the
different compounds this our 84 chemical
set along the x-axis so those are all
each of the individual chemicals and
then they're broken up into those
categories of antigen on the Left
Classen in the middle and the non
genotoxic and over on the right and you
can see on the X on the excuse me the
y-axis we're looking at probability of
being called a class 2 gene and it's
pretty obvious from this those compounds
that are in red circles that's the class
student group those have the highest
probability of being a class Gen on that
model call the antigens are much lower
and for the most part all the
genotoxicity are low as well so we take
basically you know 80 to 90 percent
productivity error probability of being
make these calls and we call that a
class again so we've done that for all
the different types of classes of
compounds the antigens and class 2 genes
and we get an assessment of the
performance of those different models
and across all of those different models
that we combine together in terms of a
priori class giin antigen versus non
junuh
classification we get a performance of
94% so 94% accuracy in terms of
predicting whether a compound was a
class gin and antigen or non genotoxic a
now that's pretty cool when we're
looking at a test at a training set but
we already know what that should be so
we need to apply sort of an external
test set so we took fifty-four
additional chemicals that had not been
part of the model we haven't seen the
data from this yet or ran them through
our system and we saw what the
predictions would be and in this case
the established mode of action of those
compounds we got 92 percent concordance
with a priori classification of those
compounds very good performance in terms
of predicting mode of action of
genotoxicity so in terms of conclusions
we have created this ad and read
multiplexed assayed that provides a
exceptionally valuable information in
terms of genotoxicity potential not just
telling you whether something is
genotoxic tor not but giving you that
extra layer of information to tell you
whether it's a class in antigen or non
genotoxic n'
though several machine learning
approaches were very successfully used
and highly performing in terms of their
ability to take those multiplex data and
turn them into mode of action call
similar to what i did before with the
micro flow s that we did an
interlaboratory performance assessment
there's another paper that's cited there
and you can see the excellent
performance that we achieved when we
ported this over to other different
laboratories in terms of having them run
in their labs and looking at the same
compounds that we did very good
performance that was achieved when we
did that inter laboratory trial so
ultimately the outcome is the Sakai
content method it can be used to
synergize with the high throughput
easy-to-use instrumentation such as you
would find in the built-in e-portfolio
and that brings us to our takeaway here
this combination of high throughput
assays with advanced machines can be
exceptionally powerful and the way that
you get that is it really comes down to
more information can lead to better
decision making the kinds of decisions
that you need to make in terms of your
pipeline whether compounds move forward
whether you keep something back on the
shelf or you're actually moving it ahead
in your pipeline this is the kind of
information that you need that's much
more informative as opposed to the
traditional way of getting this where it
was just genotoxic or not in terms of
internal decision making and going back
and
the chemists reformulate compounds or
pharmaceuticals it's much easier to work
with those people if you have more
information they should be if you
basically just come back and say it's
genotoxic fix it please that's not the
best situation for you to work with as
opposed to well it seems to have some
indications of class Regina City that
gives them a bit more information to
work with in terms of redesigning
compounds we're making continued
improvements that will hopefully deliver
additional advantages to this
combination of our methods without
mattelli emil tending machines such as
the express modes that jakob was
describing earlier and then finally in
terms of what's happening at light ron
additional new kit formats that we were
exploring to look at even deeper levels
of information going beyond mode of
action of genotoxicity and actually
looking at mechanism so we can define
some of the exact kind of DNA targets
that are there as opposed to just
looking for well this is compound is
causing DNA double strand breaks well
how is it causing those double strand
breaks is it interacting directly with
DNA or is it interacting with some of
the enzymes that are important for DNA
management
finally I'd like to acknowledge a couple
of people that have contributed to this
work first all my colleagues at electron
laboratory Steve Brewster and Bernanke
svetlana alba Sebek and my colleague
steve dirt injure these are the people
that are working in the laboratory
day-in day-out and have really
contributed to the improvements and the
advancement of the methods that I've
been describing today finally I'd like
to thank the people that I've worked
with for years at Milton a biotech Jakob
Nick and Matt drew we've established a
really nice relationship with this group
and we continue to have a great time
with that company finally I want to cite
the the funding that provided
significant amount of money for the
development of these methods so these
are both SBIR grants that were given
this to us through nie HS so we
definitely need to thank them for their
contributions in developing these assays
and with that I will say thank you and
we'll be able to take some questions
Thank You Jeffrey and Jacob for your
informative presentations we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now our speakers for answer
as many questions as time permits okay
our first question is you mentioned
using tk6 cells but do your methods work
with other cell types as well
thanks Michelle yeah so the best
majority of our work using both micro
flow and multi flow was done in TK 6 as
I described but both of those methods
have been tested with a number of other
cell lines if you look back in our
publications under the micro flow system
you will note that we have had some
publications where they used attachment
cell lines such as choke a 1 and V 79
and then multi flow has also been
applied to some of those attachments
cell lines as well as some some very
recent work that we did with Hef g2
cells as well so if you're interested in
applying other types of cell lines you
will find instructions and protocols for
that specifically in our instruction
manuals that are in the kits or if you
want some more directed guidance from us
you can contact us and we will help you
make decisions and understand what you
can and can't do with our with our
methods
thank you okay next question what
industries would typically use the multi
flow kits
um the bulk of our work has been done
with pharmaceutical companies so they're
using them primarily for drug safety
screening they have regulatory
requirements that are set up
specifically for micronucleus testing
both in vitro and in vivo so there's a
number of gene tox tests that need to be
done in order to submit compounds to say
the FDA for regulatory approval and
we're finding that companies will use
this in their early screens in order to
set themselves up better for the in
vitro micronucleus testing that they're
doing so that they can refine those
tests and understand kind of what they
have going into them
if you understand you have an antigen
you might be doing more concentrations
at a closer dose pacing if you have
class students you might have a
different kind of toxicity range that
you would be interested in looking at so
Pharma is really big into this but also
we're getting more and more interest
from other industries such as chemical
industry agrochemical industrial
chemical and then certain regulatory
agencies are also just doing research on
it as well so we have some colleagues in
the FDA the research division that are
using it for say tobacco research as
well so a number of different industries
are utilizing this particular assay
for the multiflo fa have you looked at
other test sets beyond the one mentioned
yeah so I described in there the the
training set that we used and then we
did an additional test set that was sort
of outside of that training set and that
gave us an awful lot of information to
sort of set the essay up but we did some
additional work with some other groups
one of those specifically was with Merck
and so that was a very pharmaceutical
centric kind of test set and it was
published I believe back in 2018 you can
find these if you search for our our
publications and we did very nice
performance when I believe up around the
high 80s eighty-eight percent accuracy
when we were looking at a priori
classification and then another one I'd
mentioned would be some work that we did
with our colleagues at the National
Toxicology program and this one is a
little different from a lot of the work
that we've done previously much of that
was done in sort of pharmaceutical
irrelevant compounds when the work that
we did with NTP they sent us a plate
with quite a few sort of environmentally
relevant compounds and in that case we
did the same kind of procedure running
it through multi flow and in I believe
we were getting high 90s or mid 90%
accuracy when we were looking at the
classifications that were returned on
that set of compounds as well so
whenever we put external test sets
against this we still tend to hold up
really well and get nice performance of
the multi flow acid
great thank you are the models you
generated for the multiplex athletes
transferable to other labs or would we
have to run our own test sets
um back when we were when we were
developing that assay and we we were
doing our inter laboratory trials we
looked at that quite extensively and
well we weren't really all that
satisfied with the just taking say one
data set from one company and moving it
to another one or moving say the light
Ron centric data set to another
laboratory and this is based on you know
just the different instruments that they
had the way that the cells would kind of
behave in the different laboratories we
found we weren't particularly satisfied
as sort of just transferring data but
what we came up with for that was we've
generated another test set which
includes about 24 compounds that an
individual lab would run and they can
get through that pretty quickly in that
in that 96 well plate based format and
they've generated their own set of
compounds that they would use as their
internal training set and then they
would create or we would help them
create the algorithms around those and
the prediction machine learning sort of
systems that they would then apply to
their new compounds that they would be
running in fact this is what we've done
when we've set up other contract
research organizations that are running
this assay so we have gone and basically
sort of installed the assay at their
site using that 24 compound set and now
they're moving ahead with a sort of
client fee-for-service work and they're
basing it on that 24 compound set that
we initially installed for them
thank you okay it looks like we have one
more question here and that is could you
give us more detail on the mechanism of
action kit to describe at the end of
your talk right so I spent a lot of time
talking about what we sort of consider
the base assay or like standard multi
flow and that essentially gives you the
information that I spent that time on
which was genotoxicity yes/no and then
additional levels of mode of actions so
whether it's class genic and eugenic or
non genotoxic we focused in on some of
those specific modes of action and most
heavily in on the an eugenic mode of
action and we have devised what we're
calling our antigen molecular mechanism
assay it's still based off of multi flow
so it's the same platform but we have
some in and out a few different
antibodies and some components that are
in that kit and what it's really suited
for is once you've made that first
classification with the base multi flow
assay then you would move forward the
antigens that you discovered or revealed
in your assessment and you would dive a
little deeper and look at them in a bit
more of a mechanism of action kind of
process so instead of mode we're looking
at mechanism and we've been able to find
that it can help you distinguish between
two major classes of antigens that we've
looked at and those are being tubulin
disruptors so binders or stabilizers and
then the other class would be protein
kinase inhibitors primarily working
through an Aurora kinase inhibition
mechanism so we have a system that will
now allow you to further differentiate
not only if it's an antigen but also
whether it is disrupting tubules like a
tubulin poison or if it's a protein
kinase inhibitor so that is a kick that
we are currently testing right now and
sort of another inter laboratory
validation trial to see that it can be
transferred to other laboratories we
hope to have that out on the market
pretty soon but just keep in contact
with us and we'll definitely won't be
keeping that secrets you'll know about
it when it will become commercially
available now in terms of other assays
that we're working on there's another
sort of application that where we're
piloting
that we're trying to get out of the
market eventually and that it was going
to be looking at sort of a class-2 genic
mode of action but determining whether
they are direct DNA reactive class
cheon's or whether they're indirect so
depending upon whether they're binding
to DNA or whether they are say
interrupting enzymes and other DNA
manufacturing and handling proteins you
can have different types of class to
genetic activity so in that case we've
got other means of looking at that and
determining not only again class agenda
s'ti as a mode of action but also the
mechanism by which it is interacting
with DNA and then finally we're looking
at some other kits that we'll be
hopefully in the future looking at
things like reactive oxygen species
mitochondria potential that kind of
thing that are fairly relevant modes of
cytotoxicity that can kind of come into
play when you start talking about non
genotoxic mechanisms of action that we
would like to differentiate from those
more predominant class to genic and
eugenic modes of genotoxicity so we're
continuing to sort of develop and evolve
within this multi flow platform and
hopefully we'll continue to have more
and more kits out in the future
thank you I would like to once again
thank both of our speakers for their
informative presentations do either if
you have any final comments for our
audience
yeah Thank You Michelle and I want to
also to thank you again very much Jeff
for sharing your expert knowledge on
genotoxicity testing with us and I want
to advise everybody to if you want to
have further information to go to our
website Muslim biotech to come and
download our application or Don
high-throughput you know Texas City
testing and which in consist the max
content and in vitro micro flow kids
from Latin and thanks also the audience
for listening
yeah I'll follow up on it really quickly
I want to thank Jakob and Milt ne for
inviting us here today so I could give
you the presentation really appreciate
the the work and the collaboration that
we've had throughout the years you can
see it's a good team coming together
with meltonian like Tron we've been able
to really sort of leverage the
technology side and the methodology side
between our two companies and it's it's
really win-win for us I want to thank
Michelle for coordinating this she did a
really excellent job coaching us through
this and then bringing this to you guys
so my last closing thank you we'll go
out to the audience and for tuning in
today and listening along and again if
you have any questions yet get through
the channels that Jakob is described or
contact us directly at light Ron and we
will give you the support that you need
thanks again
we would also like to thank lab herbs
and art sponsor Milton biotech our
underwriting today's educational webcast
this blood pass can be viewed on demand
laberd's will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event until next time goodbye